I started singing and you should see
that the people who are running the
auditions faces one one woman gasped
she held her mouth they could their
faces they could not hide their
disappointment in how terrible
[Music]
I am in studio in LA
Tom Takhar is holding down the fort in
New York with Ian's finance how's your
butthole but in a caring way yeah it's
doing great thank you so much feels good
this morning um feels good most mornings
I can't arete I can't remember the last
time my butthole didn't feel great
that's but really like you know what um
let me introduce our guest I am so
excited and proud to introduce my friend
my dance partner I never thought I would
say those words might dance partner Gleb
Savchenko everyone we are we in it to
win it
yes okay you're hilarious that's not
what you said
when we were on the press looks like a
dancer when she don't move sleeping yeah
I do I do better what I'm just standing
hit a pose there are times when Gleb
will position my body in the way that
it's supposed to be and he's like see
this is it this is it and I'll be like I
feel like my organs are shutting down I
will be so twisted and I'm like how am I
supposed to find that he'll be like that
line those lines are great I'm like
that's not a line I have scoliosis it's
been so much fun with this guy I you
know you watch the show Dancing with the
Stars Club has been on it what does what
number season is this for you as a pro
nine
nine seasons you've done nine seasons as
a pro but I've done it in different
country different countries yeah I mean
they told me yesterday there are 52
countries where did they do Dancing with
the Stars yeah isn't that insane
so club has done many different versions
worldwide but he's been on the American
version for how many seasons now as a
pro since season 16 since season 16 and
now we're in season 27 so I missed a
couple of them yeah he was in an Audi
was she traveling and total it was like
809 yes you've worked with eight or nine
celebrities at this point stars and
train them I mean you don't really you
see it on the show and I never really
watched the show but I would always you
know you hear sound bites you hear
celebrities talk about their experience
on the show and they always say like
their partners and them become so close
and it's such a it's so you spend so
much time together and you go yeah yeah
yeah I mean Gleb is now one of my best
friends because I I dance with him every
day it is such a it's such an intimate
relationship I I know that I'll know
this man for the rest of my life which
is weird I told him the other day one of
we're gonna be at each other's funerals
one of us is gonna go to each other you
know isn't that a weird thing to say to
someone but it's true in your life yeah
yeah that's great
that's a great idea
but Gleb Gleb is someone that I you know
when I did my research when I knew I was
gonna do the show and I was looking at
all the dancers I was like who do I want
and he was like my number one pick and
then I walked into the room to meet him
and I was yeah it was the first day one
of mad I was like oh my god I'm gonna
dance with this girl
yeah and that we did a little twirl
remember like I turn you on to the arm
and you were like I was like oh my god I
got so excited until the first rehearsal
no but then you know now we're like 10
days in and now I'm actually excited for
this before I know Gleb
gleb took a shift the other day like
it's we've been we've been through some
big ups and downs like it did not start
great but it was still early enough that
I wasn't getting totally discouraged
then how do you feel now tell me like I
want to know okay
so glad I practiced last night and I
because I didn't want to disappoint you
today because our last rehearsal you
were a little bit there was a we just
both get frustrated at that my body
doesn't do what my mind knows what I've
done what I've done over like I will do
a dance move that we will perfect I'll
do it like 50 times right like he'll
drill me so that it's muscle memory you
know and then we turn on the music and I
I completely forget it and he had to
like leave the room the other day he was
so frustrated and I was frustrated with
myself I just fall to the ground I go no
it's like we just did this it's I mean I
have I've never been on that side of
things where I'm teaching someone
something and they have it and they and
they get it and you're so proud of them
and then they lose it as if they never
knew it but it must be it must be
frustrating it's hard to move to the to
to the music you know if you'd ever done
before like just I know but it's
possible yeah yeah you're gonna be great
I've already like done things that I
didn't think I could do like I watched
the video we record ourselves at at
rehearsal and then I watch it back and I
was watching I was watching it in
slow-mo last night and really going over
it and then practicing it a lot
here's how I feel glad to be honest I I
want I got in a wormhole yesterday Club
and I were both on the same flight and I
he was sitting next to vivica a fox I
was sitting there just some guy it's
just some guy I don't even know and I
was I got into a Dancing with the Stars
wormhole and I watched too many videos
and I got in my head oh no I watched
zendaya
too much which you were in one of her
dances the salsa was zendaya if I dance
the rest of my life every day trained
like an Olympian
I would never even be able to do
one-tenth of that day I mean she was so
perfect I mean and you you were that was
a fun dance right that was so it was so
good and then I and that's the problem
is like I can't be watching these other
videos I have to just like be competing
against me I have to compare myself to
myself just compare yourself to yourself
and try to be better than you were
yesterday yeah I don't know that I'm
better than I was yesterday if you look
at the first video that was shot we just
met yeah look at the video now from like
yesterday it's totally different things
yeah yeah see important dancer remember
your homework you have to look in the
mirror every morning and say to yourself
I am a dancer yeah club gives me
homework
Club really had a powerful moment with
me the other day where he's like and it
was it was real you were like mad and I
liked it because the other day you like
snapped into we have a lot of fun Gleb
is a really fun funny guy and we joke a
lot and we get a lot of work done but we
have moments of like when I mess up we
joke about it but the other day you were
frustrated and I could tell that you
came in with a different attitude of
like I'm gonna work this bitch today
like she like we were doing we were like
doing cardio like I was we were sweating
and and you at a moment later on in the
rehearsal where you were like you are
you are you are a funny person but you
are not if you would like you note he
said the greatest God he was like you
you do jokes but you are not a joke
you're not a joke Nicky you're not a
joke
you are a Victoria's Secret supermodel
which is like secretly what I always
want to be so you like really nailed it
he was like you are like on the runway
super sexy you have to you have to be
sexy and I'd like I just never have felt
this is a challenge for me is to be sexy
into I can act sexy like I can act it
but to actually be it and believe it is
a totally different thing so I'm really
I'm really trying like I put on when I
do my makeup I put on my music and I
just like I just dance around like a
real like I just
I'm trying to like whose sexuality
wherever I go I want everyone like
wanting to me wherever I go because
I that's like I need to get in that
mindset for this dance of being like
really powerful really sexy and and not
like goofy because it's so easy for me
to like make a goofy face or make a
goofy movie one of the kindest new song
Kanye's which one oh yeah that why don't
you oh yeah it's about us about such a
yeah there's a what is it cut inhale
well I've just said it's Kanye and lil
something yeah it's a it's it's it's so
hard and I and I still have to learn
another dance before who's making these
dances up Gleb Gleb Gleb Gleb is you
don't understand what these guys do like
he choreographs the dances he has to
teach them to be so heat and literally
the it is a really it's really hard to
teach someone who's never done a thing
when you're the best edit in the world I
mean Gleb has been dancing since he was
7 he is he's one of the best dancers in
the world he is a world champion I mean
it's just true you are you're like a
world but you've got the World
Championships you've gotten really close
and you would have won them had you been
in the right country to win them because
there's a lot of politics going on in
the world of dancing well I've literally
as respected as one of the best dancers
in the world I know that and on the show
he just he stands out like you know even
amongst everyone no offense to the other
dancers but your eye is drawn to glad
what he's dancing he just has a style
that is very I don't even know anything
about dancing and I'm like there's
something special going on with that guy
and but he it's it's really jumped they
choreograph it he comes up with the
concept he has a whole creative vision
for it and the other day like it was so
weird we were doing the Dan
and there's a part in the dance where I
step III walk away like I see him and
I'm like hey you what's up and then and
then I kind of walk away from him cuz
I'm like I'm done with you and then I
and then I I try to fight to take two
steps and then I go wait a second I want
to go back to him and he's like and he's
telling me he's like Nikki's so the
dance is you you walk away and then you
turn around and you come back and you
realize no like I'm not done with him
and I'm like do you know my life like
behind this dance
he's choreographed a dance that is my
love life of just like going away coming
back going away coming back just try to
put on the Russian accent yeah I mean
you you have a Russian accent I know you
want to lose it but it is very strong
and it's good though I don't think you
should lose it I'm gonna keep it I want
it I want to be able to oh I want to be
able to keep it but if I want to just
get rid of it so no one knows that can
you try to do can you try to do like the
most American accent you can do I can
accent like you you like you speak now
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay um Club I can't
dance clap I can't dance but Gleb your
story is really fascinating like you're
you're a hot guy who a lot of people can
write off as like oh he's just like a
hot dancer hot dude I could write you
off that way and I will I'll continue to
write but I also do know the truth about
you which is like you what got you into
dancing I find your story kind of
fascinating my group in Moscow right
grandmother so what happened yeah I grew
up in Moscow I was 7 years old a really
like a girl in my class you know we were
in one class and she joined dancing and
they asked my grandma to go inside me
out because I just wanted to see her
more though the girl the girl yeah and
that's how I started and then you know
eventually I start dancing with her and
then she quit dancing because her
parents moved and then but like didn't
you you were in this dance class and
people who go to dance classes like
Scout talent stop by and you were just
in this and they were like that hasn't
we yeah we there was like a local small
competition where judges from the whole
town came in to judge and one judge came
up to my parents and said this guy Got
Talent
why don't you kind of like push a little
harder and you know have private lessons
and you know just more training that's
what my parents did and that's how I got
into it and then I never stopped yeah
and um where's the girl and at what no
no the girl was dance so where did you
so so I like the turn in the story where
you were dancing in Russia and then you
got to a place where you were great I
mean how old were you were 14 yeah so
what happened I was dancing dancing
dancing we won a lot of competitions I
had I don't know 10 12 different
partners every single like every half a
year I don't know why I was changing
partners and by the by the age of 14 I
knew it's gonna be my career yeah Wow
yeah sir yeah but it was hard like in
Russia scarred with everything you know
like the mentality of the parents is
that if you do something gotta be great
at it otherwise there's no point invest
money and time into it and if you don't
do it right now and you don't deliver
you we're not gonna do it anymore that's
what my my parents mean salad it was
like this and if we do it it's not just
a hobby it's a hundred percent your
career and it's in everything like
people play hockey or dancing or soccer
or anything else yeah so and they pushed
for sports till the point where they
reached like we have to pay for private
lessons we have to you know afford a
dance clothes and shoes it was
everything was really expensive it was
like brought from overseas because
nothing's been
used in Russia at that time it was like
25 years ago and I you know we were
dancing we're in the good level but
there was no way much treat how much
dancing were you doing when you were you
would go to school and you would go
right to dancing afterwards like three
hours every day after school three four
Wow yeah yeah with a partner and then
every weekend we go and travel maybe
different towns to compete and do the
lowliest local competitions and we're at
that point we're like top five in Russia
at the Russian championship but I at
that point like I understand there's no
way even if I'll be the greatest dancer
and better than everybody else I'll be
number one or two to be able to go to
the World Championship to represent the
country to represent Russia you would
have to be one or two yeah two couples
representing and to be in that position
you would need to have a lot of money
you don't get the best training the best
travel everything exactly so you saw you
go I want to compete on a world level
and for me to do that I'd have to be the
two of the best which I probably am
skill wise but so my teacher yeah my
teacher came up to me and said listen
you gotta just change the country of
representation you have to go somewhere
else and just represent that country to
be able to go to the World Championship
and you know you can win the world
championship and everybody's gonna know
about you but you have to you know be
one a second second first the second
place so I thought about it and there
was like where's the closest place on
the map and there's just like a lot via
Lithuania Estonia Finland there's
everything like all around Russia was
just overnight train right so I just got
a visa to Lithuania and I went to
Lithuania because my teachers wife lived
there and kind of like knew the whole
scene yeah you really go there to find a
girl a girl to find a partner find a
partner and you were how old I was 15 so
you're 15 and you took a train to
Lithuania yeah to go fought to go meet a
potential partner yeah
and you get there and what does that
like do you want a date do you just like
meet in the dance studio and then just
start dancing like what no I remember I
was in so I got there I took a bus I
hadn't the address so I took a bus to
the place where that coach lived yeah
and I was just sleeping like in one room
she put me in there for like two nights
and then we just went to the dance
studio and she had a few girls that I
tried out with and then there was a
competition the next day and I saw this
girl she was really really good I was
like I wanna dance with her she goes
there's no way you'll be able to dance
with her because she you know they're
number one in here she has a partner she
already has a partner and I didn't dance
with her so it was like I left told my
dad like I need another 300 dollars to
go to Latvia cuz there's another girl my
dad like are you crazy like what are you
doing like you're 15 years old you
better go and like and study and do
something that it's you know eventually
is gonna make you money I was like no I
wanna dance so I went to Latvia and then
I went to stony and then went back to
Lithuania and I was just I spent
probably like eight months traveling
around Europe just trying out with all
these different girls yeah and then I it
was just you know I lost all hope I was
one day in Moscow just sitting there and
be like you know I don't know I'm just
gonna continue dance here and find
another girl here and then I got a phone
call from parents of this girl that I
tried out from Latvia and they were like
listen I think it's gonna work you know
you just got to figure it out how you're
gonna come to you know and live here
like how you gonna support I was like
what about it that got this yeah which
in my head I was like yes yes that
really gives me a lot of hope when you
go we got this yeah you tell me we got
this all the time no I know we'll find a
way you say we've got this to me so
often and now I know what that really
meant which is it's fourteen-year-old
glove being like story short I went
there started dancing with her won all
the championships and then we went to
the 20 that was a funny thing it was the
open Lithuanian championship we'll win
there
we won we got first place and that girl
who didn't want to dance with me the
girls yeah now club did you were picking
a dance partner does it always come down
to skill or when you're a 14 year old
you know pubescent boy who's like is
there any part of you that's like yes
she's she's great but then there's this
girl that's a little less great but
she's super hot I want to dance does
that play into it at all when you dance
with someone that there's gonna be a
you're gonna be especially at that age
hormones are raging you're gonna end up
hooking up with that person probably at
that age of you're both single young
adolescent kids the thing is like when I
danced with that girl we didn't hook up
oh wow
she wasn't really you weren't attracted
yeah and then you one or it was totally
on the table so she was into you but you
were not feeling it yeah yeah yeah where
is she now
so then I want to get to when you came
to America like how did you first get
here and why were you coming here oh I
want to talk about where you got just so
you weren't like down and out you were
struck you were out of money and then
something an opportunity came came into
your lap which was your face yeah yeah
so I danced with a girl and then we
didn't for two years I fell in love with
another girl what broke you we're about
to go to world championships with one
partner and then you fell in love with
another dancer who was not as skilled
you switched partners right before the
world championship right and you did not
win no because your partner sucked yes
she was super hot okay so then you lost
the world championships yeah I came back
to Moscow like and I said to my dad I
was like what am I supposed to do he was
like well you really screwed up like you
go and figure it out yourself so I had
no money I had
pretty much like no place to live how
old were you I was 19 okay yeah 18 yeah
and I start working the fitness center
doing some salsa classes yeah yeah and
this girl again we got another girl came
up to me she goes like listen have you
ever tried model and was like modeling
I mean sure let's try it yeah so she
took me to this model agency and it took
off you know I became like one of the
top models had done like a lot a bunch
of different commercials in Russia you
were like Russia I was like the guy yeah
like Gigi Hadid here yes in Russia in
Russia yeah and then I was like you know
it's too small I gotta go in explore
like I gotta go yeah big in Russia but I
want to be big elsewhere I didn't you
had bigger dreams and you wanted to
dance still I mean did you think about
modeling were you like oh that's just
gonna be my career that wasn't in any
part of you that said I'll put I'll
leave dancing behind it was always
because it was like I've danced for so
many years and dancing was always my
life so I could easily go and teach and
make some money that I can pursue some
other career yes I want to do modelling
yes so we're gonna get to gleb coming to
America after the next break because
he's famous and Russia at this point as
a model he's his faces everywhere he's
in every print thing he's uncle's you're
making lots of money and then you decide
to go to America and things take a turn
and we'll get to that when we get back
I'm in studio in Los Angeles with my
dance partner on Dancing with the Stars
season 27 which premieres September 24th
live we're gonna be dancing live what
what happens if I fall Gleb just own it
the music keeps going and then I stand
up and I take it from wherever we are
yeah I know he's gonna go viral yeah I
know epic fall oh my god I was watching
yesterday I said I got into like a
wormhole of like watching Dancing with
the Stars stuff and I like yeah fails
and there haven't been that many there's
been like one girl who like forgot her
moves I forget who it was but like
what's
what's for you since you've been on the
show what's been like the craziest thing
that's happened live in your experience
craziest thing is when someone has a
cramp and like you can't really move oh
my god
only she had that with Max when they did
a rumba and Max had a cramp on his leg
and he could not like they were doing
just like like not a live but he was
like dipping her somewhere he had a
crumpet like he was like oh like start
shaking oh man to raise the hand to like
oh they're almost stop the music he just
kind of pushed through continued but it
was like it was pretty bad but like
things like for example you're doing a
lift and the live doesn't work and
you're like she's about to fall and
there's like oh my god it's like when we
did a freestyle with Jenna yeah I was so
sick I was so exhausted I was just so
tired and we had this lift where she
jumps on my shoulders and I have to like
catch her and start running forward yeah
so I start like I don't know what
happened but I was like I started
running forward and I almost fell i I
thought I'm like I'm falling yeah
moments like that but everything else is
fine what's your favorite part of the
live show I mean the dancing is where
you're probably feeling it's just the
exciting like excitement in the studio
like all these people are watching you
and they're all so excited you just feel
the thousand people right like isn't it
a big big crowd I mean for a live
television taping a thousand people is a
huge crowd it looks a lot smaller than
that on TV and then not to mention the
13 to 18 million people who watch it
every week watching at home and then
voting which you have to vote for me and
gleb to keep us in the competition so
please set your DVRs for September 24th
and 25th we will be dancing we will need
your votes team Gleb glaze is what I'm
calling us hashtag blood plays BB glaze
GLA ze what is a I mean yeah I guess my
biggest fear is just up and then
realizing I up and then
up more and then it just spirals out of
control well you got to put you got to
catch yourself like even if you make a
mistake you have to kind of go back
keep it together you know don't let it
because they don't know your steps they
don't know your routine it's only me and
you who knows this yes and everything
make it little mistake just keep going
keep pushing through and make sure you
don't you know show it on your face and
just kind of like fake it until you make
it
yes you know what I mean yes what are
you bad at Gleb what I'm bad at yeah
what are you saying you can't sing would
you ever do a set would you ever do a
singing with the Stars sure you would I
would do it
Gleb I have to say recently I think two
weeks ago one farming with the stars in
the UK
what celebs on the farm it's gone slips
in the farm and it's literally a farming
show Gleb is it as a celebrity is a bona
fide celebrity in the UK he has a number
two selling calendar yes number three
selling calendar right behind one
direction and and David Gleb Savchenko
is number three he has a I can't wait to
get this calendar choose 2019 wait it's
on the way here to the studio right now
I can't will you give me one and Gleb
also has a line of underwear yes which
you said you were gonna give me because
I ran out of underwear you seriously
bring me some yes will you bring me cuz
they always forget every single pair is
designed based on a dance style yes so I
want the salsa kind yeah you got it okay
the chunky salsa kind do you have a
dougie kind yeah so Gleb let's go back
to your story you end up in America how
cuz you you you had you had bigger
aspirations you were modeling and in
music videos you were in print ads you
were commercials you were everywhere
everywhere you had the world at your
fingertips you could have anything you
want you were a single guy you were
slaying it was the best time oh my god
was it the best the best I mean you were
partying all the time drinking like a
true Russian you said that the other day
we were talking about hangovers and you
were like oh man I was invincible it
when I think I could literally go for
like two days
without sleep wake up in the morning go
to work come back just repeat it again
and yeah do it like for 3-4 days yeah
now if I have like one or two drinks the
next morning I'm like oh my god I can't
wake up yes yeah yeah yeah so you moved
to America to America how did you what
did you do you move to Brooklyn yet to
become like a world-famous model male
model yeah yeah and that was like
nothing happened you know I was just
going from casting to casting and there
was just nothing happened so it was like
I ran out of money I started teaching at
like local dance studio yeah in New York
in the city and I was just doing it and
then I started hosting this little
Russian TV program called time out for
the Russian community we were just
taking interviews from all these
different famous people and checking out
what's happening in the city to kind of
let know the Russian community what's
actually happening because you know you
don't realize that but a lot of people
who back in the day move from you know
Ukraine or Russia to America and they
moved to Brooklyn some of them not even
being in the city ever so they it's like
their own world you know in Brooklyn
deliv there and yeah they don't go
outside of that area yes so we were
trying to go around and just kind of
like talk about and let them know what's
happening so host of that show who said
that show nothing happened nothing
happened and I was just I wasn't back to
dancing I started competing again and I
I left I left New York I went back to
Moscow and went to Hong Kong yeah
because there was money to be made in
Hong Kong teaching right the Japanese
want to learn how to dance
Chinese Chinese
my god literally just learned
[Music]
you